Hello.
My name is John Bines and I’m a writer.
I thought about doing this video for awhile
but had held off because I’ve been actually
in the middle of transitioning.
I recently moved out to Los Angeles to further
my career as a writer and I’d like to take
a moment to tell you a little about myself.
I’ve been in film and television now for
over 20 years.
I started out after engaging in a lucrative
career in computer technologies and decided
that I really wanted to pursue my lifelong
goal to becoming a television and film writer.
I quit my job and started working as a PA
(production assistant) on various music videos
and other projects.
I eventually worked my way up over a number
of years to becoming an editor working for
people like Tom Fontana and Barry Levinson
and Dave Chappelle and many others.
After awhile I realized that my career was
kind of stalemating as an editor and I started
to question what I was doing.
You know, like a shark at the bottom of the
ocean (I always like to use this as a parable)…like
a shark at the bottom of the ocean, in this
business you have to constantly keep moving.
If you don’t, you literally will die.
After awhile of editing for a number of people
for great, amazing projects, I decided to
seriously start writing.
I started to write spec scripts for shows
that I had worked on.
And writing original ideas of my own in the
form of screenplays and even started a novel.
But I quickly found that as challenging as
it was reaching the goal to become an editor,
my desire to become a writer was even more
challenging.
I had become very ill with a terminal illness
and very shortly after my faithful companion
dog (Fubu) of eleven years at the time had
been mauled by a pit bull.
And in the mauling, I broke my hand actually
while the dog was mauling my dog trying to
get him off of him.
And my dog has since healed up and he’s
an amazing testament to courage, which is
one of the reasons why I wanted to actually
make this video was about courage and sometimes
the courage it takes to continually pursue
your goals.
Particularly if you want to become a writer
or stay even in the industry of film and television.
So I’m there at my house with a broken hand
and healing a mauled dog and still dealing
with the terminal illness.
I still had friends I was helping.
I’ve always been a very generous person
and some friends were living with me and others
I was actually taking care of financially.
And I started to ask myself, like at what
point is too much?
Is enough, enough?
Where you keep giving of yourself and you’re
constantly having to take care of your own
self and others.
And I started to think, what if you put that
burden on a 12-year-old boy?
Well, that actually created a television pilot
that I wrote called THE HEALER.
It’s about a 12-year-old immigrant boy who
was gifted…or you could say cursed…with
the ability to heal.
He teams up with a renegade, rogue CIA ex-AA
operative who is trained to kill (female operative)
and they actually go on an adventure to save
the world.
It’s a parable loosely based on the narrative
of Jesus Christ but more importantly reflective
of what I felt I was going through in my own
life.
One of the things I like to do is I write
about things that speak to me, things that
are personal to me.
And through all of my experiences in this
business and continually working I’ve always
found that no matter how far I think I’ve
gone, I have so much farther to go and sometimes
I think I’m starting all over again.
Which I have, I’ve recently moved to the
Los Angeles area to pursue a career in television
and hopefully to meet other writers and producers.
I got an opportunity to direct a short film
and that was amazing and really trying to
push to pursue this career that I’ve set
out upon over 20 years ago.
So again my call of action is hopefully to
entice other producers to contact me or reach
out to me or reach out to me that I can build
relationships with to learn from and hopefully
to use my skills to help them and hopefully
get some information as to how I can further
my career as to how I can possibly work with
various people on different projects.
One of the things I make a part of my day
(my daily regime) is watching videos from
Film Courage.
All of the information (the amazing information),
the experiences of other writers really serve
to bolster my own sometimes lofty goals (I
call them) and also to let people know that
sometimes this road is not a fast one (it
takes awhile).
But my commitment, people ask me all of the
time “Why are you still doing this?”
You know to me writing and creating dialogue
is intrinsic to me as the color of my skin
or my being a male for that matter.
Again, this is to encourage others to hopefully
stay on your path and also another way of
my reaching out and hopefully expanding on
my contacts and people that can hopefully
help me further my goals.
I just want to say thank you all and have
a good day and may we all reach our goals
no matter how lofty they seem to be and just
stay on your path and stick to what you’re
doing and eventually things will work out.
Thank you!
Contact John Bines to read THE HEALER